[Music]
today is Cyber Monday did you know that
today is Cyber Monday which means
tomorrow is I was drunk when I bought
all that crap Tuesday do people have you
got bought anything today actually I did
what'd you buy I bought some bottles of
hot sauce as you can tell this was
unrehearsed banter runnin low on hot
sauce really nice I mean I was on the
clock that was already earning money I
figured why not gonna make the best of
it what I do in my office Conan I know
your hot sauce yeah it's the only reason
you're on the computer I can't believe
this a Christian college is suing the
Obama administration over its health
care law yeah they're citing the part in
the Bible where Jesus refuses to heal a
leper because it's a pre-existing
condition that part good who saw the
movie Lincoln anyone here see it you
know the movie Lincoln came in third at
the box office this weekend yeah however
experts agree it's still not Lincoln's
worst time at the theater
which
yeah
hillwood whoo that joke yeah that's
right : cuz of the assassination at all
do you hear this the kid on the show two
and a Half Men you know the kid actor
Angus T Jones just gave an interview
where he called the show filthy and said
it goes against his Christian values and
he cashed a check for 1 million dollars
and in that order Burbank's in the news
right here our town Burbank sending are
all from there we only get locals right
here in Burbank they've installed the
world's first caviar vending machine
caviar vending machine yeah it's all
part of an initiative to cheer up Mitt
Romney yeah two story a new study
reveals that contrary to popular belief
sex with a pregnant woman will not
induce labor damn there goes my best
pick-up line it always worked for me
back in the day pretended to say that
this new study just came out ladies and
gentlemen the average American now
weighs 176 pounds
176 that may not sound too bad to you
but the study was conducted at
elementary schools it's true story I
didn't make that up
this odd that you would tell that in a
monologue of it's a true story it's I
mostly tell true things out here kind of
a bummer
yeah games ever in Florida a 69 year old
woman 69 was arrested for stealing
hundreds of dollars worth of lingerie
authorities released her after she
threatened to model the lingerie also
true that really happened I'm gonna do
it no she's got the thong let's get out
of here guys were diving out the window